you
in our eye on earth series a bipartisan
group of senators is announcing new
action on climate change only on CBS
this morning some prominent Republicans
are joining Democrats to address the
crisis scientists warn climate change
could have dire consequences and soon
Nancy Cordes spoke with members of both
parties on an issue Democrats often
champion while Republicans typically
push aside she's on Capitol Hill
Nancy what changed well the biggest
thing that changed Anthony is public
opinion it has evolved rather quickly
and most Americans according to the
polls now view climate change as a major
threat the question is can this new
bipartisan group get past the political
divide that still exists here in
Congress on this issue from the Arctic
to the Amazon the floods flames and
melting ice are impossible to ignore now
even in Congress the climate is changing
we look a bit like Neanderthals it's
real we've got to take action Utah's
Mitt Romney is one of four Republicans
three Democrats and one independent who
just joined the Senate's first
bipartisan climate caucus my expectation
is that we will start by listening it's
the brainchild of Delaware Democrat
Chris Coons and Indiana Republican Mike
Ron I've got four kids that took a poll
among them what do you think about this
idea they love it a departure from the
climate science skepticism the GOP has
embraced in recent years I believe that
human activity is causing these dramatic
changes to our climate that's very very
food very unseasonal so mr. president
says there are still some Republican
senators who think that cold winter
weather is a sign that the climate isn't
changing I think science is more and
more clear and I think people will
either be convinced or not as time goes
on you know I think many probably just
we're not willing to say it but to me
it's chemistry and physics I'm not going
to deny that Democrat jeanne Shaheen can
already see the impacts in New Hampshire
our ski
industry is affected our snowmobiling
our maple sugaring industry so many
things that people can see have all of
you seen changes in your own States
absolutely it's striking in Delaware
just how much it's impacting everything
from sports fishing commercial fishing
their first move a meeting with CEOs
some of them pushing a carbon tax
it's an early test of the group's
ambition and clout if we go there right
away I think we'll probably be doing the
whole thing a disservice do you have to
cap or at the very least discourage
emissions in order to make a difference
oh I'm not going to say any half-two
with regards to to climate I think I
think all the ideals will be on the
table there's a dozen different areas
where we are hopeful that there is some
low-hanging fruit that can be moved
forward on a bipartisan basis means
angus King says strength in numbers will
help my philosophy is let's take small
steps find some things we can succeed on
scientists insist nations must act now
with millions at risk from rising
temperatures and sea levels and with the
crisis threatening to cut the US economy
by up to 10% by century's end these
senators hope Congress can catch up I do
believe that old saying is true which is
when they feel the heat they'll see the
light people who might otherwise be more
inclined to slow things down are going
to say we've got to respond the group
wants to introduce legislation by next
year but they have a challenge in
winning over the White House which just
began the process of withdrawing from
the Paris climate Accords this week and
has rolled back dozens of environmental
rules Tony since taking office three
years ago yeah Nancy they've got a
potential blockade there at the White
House they've also got a win over the
rest of Congress but it is a start and
that's good news Nancy thank you very
much